if y'all are hard balling don't lower
your standards and be upfront about what
you want because you know time is
precious and you don't want to waste it
dating someone that wasn't your match in
the first place what the [ __ ] is going
on i
like to party
jesus this is unwaxed get in loser we're
going shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone do we just become best friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the
unwaxed podcast with your favorite
sisters
sophia
and sistine
you guys you guys
what is happening
this feels weird
if you're listening to the podcast right
now you're probably wondering why
sophia's
audio sounds drastically different from
my audio different as in better
because well
using a fake mic that's not even
attached to the tv
you guys
sophia jumps on this zoom call by the
way we're recording today's episode
via zoom because she's in florida i'm in
los angeles which we will explain very
soon
but she comes on looking so professional
with this gorgeous blue microphone and i
thought
well i need one too to look like a
professional podcast host but mine's not
even plugged in and i'm still talking
into it as if it's a working book no and
the best part system is you think you're
the only fraud in the group i'm
currently sitting in mom's bathroom
while you're actually having beautiful
lighting i can't find a room to sit in
so i'm in the bathroom there's a shower
over there there's a closet over there
and we're just thinking what works
the acoustics sound great for you though
they probably do do i sound great
do you hear me you sound you sound like
you're echoing
in a cool way you know kind of like yeah
okay i like that i like that well so
assessing said i'm in florida she's in
la and you know it's kind of a rarity to
be apart for this long and i think we
weren't planning on not seeing each
other for like two weeks
sophia
pulled the rug out from beneath me
to say
unless a fewer words
i wasn't expecting her to be apart from
me
we spent the holiday in in florida and
we were supposed to continue our new
year's plans together elsewhere
and sophia goes
psych i'm staying here peace out have a
good time okay i wish
that it was that easy and i just
randomly was like all right cysteine
screw you screw this i'm staying in
florida no no no but i'll get into
exactly why i end up not going with you
but
we spent yeah new year's apart so steen
was in sun valley with her boyfriend and
we can get into that because if you guys
know us we don't ski
we don't know snow i don't know the last
time either of us have actually been in
snow
yeah i was in sunny humid florida with
sylvester and jen so that was and no one
else like i didn't have scarlet with me
it was me and the dogs
and so yeah um i kind of want to get
into actually if i didn't really ask you
exactly what you ended up doing
in somebody like how was it how was new
year's how is it different from l.a you
know how we always say that we
manifest things too hard sometimes and
then they come true and we're like ah
you know
we didn't mean it you know it was a joke
when i put skiing on my vision board
last year
i didn't think i would actually go
skiing no
in theory you know dressing up to go
skiing and putting on a onesie and
wearing little ear muffs like all of
that sounds really cute but there's
nothing cute about negative four
temperatures which i was in no and this
is the funniest way so see the funniest
part is we in florida before she left we
looked at what the temperature was and
we were like okay so it seems like it's
14. fine and that goes the scene scroll
down what does it say next to feels like
and he said it felt like negative one
no but see
when i got there
it was a high of 2 degrees
so
this is a girl
who doesn't even own a full length
t-shirt i only have crop tops so now i
have to figure out how to bundle how to
layer how to go skiing with a group of
people that are actually really good at
skiing so that was also another thing
that i was so nervous about was not only
am i trying to impress my new boyfriend
right and his friends at skiing i'm
trying to be able to keep up with people
that know how to do and i haven't seen
snow in 10 years let alone skiing it 10
years no and so
they they were so sweet they um
actually was really embarrassing right
when we got to the mountain to do the
first run think of cysteine why don't
you go
on the bunny hill just to get your feet
warm
that's a good i i by the way
they should yes
but i don't think you understand i
thought it was a little bit steep a
little bit hard
it was
at like a one degree angle it was almost
a flat surface it wasn't even a hill and
i was going up this little conveyor belt
right on my skis to go up this tiny
mountain and in front of me there's a
toddler and behind me there's a toddler
and then there's me in the middle
i know it gets worse
as if i'm like crying cause it's so
funny as if that wasn't embarrassing
enough and they're all standing there
laughing watching these toddlers go whip
down
i start to slide backwards on the
conveyor belt
and i'm starting to slide into this all
these toddlers and it's becoming a
domino effect of
me hitting a toddler then the toddler
hitting another one then another one and
i'm ruining the entire line and the guy
the little kid behind me is like stop
hitting me so she said i was like i've
never done this before give me a break
so anyway i crush the bunny hill we go
up and i was actually very impressed
with my skills i only felt like three
times
um
but then i got cocky which is something
i need to work on because i think that i
can do more than i can and then i
started going down
way harder mountains to keep up with
them and i literally had to slide on my
ass like all the way down because i
could not do it it took me about 35
minutes longer
do you think you got better though
i'll tell you this
i don't know if i got better i'm just
proud of myself um but i don't need to
do it again like i'm good for the next
10 years
gotcha
i don't know i i totally respect and
admire people that are like i'm a skier
but extreme sports to me
is not a vacation
you know if you have to work
if you have to wear a helmet to have fun
that's not my version of fun you know
but like that's that's fair that's fair
and how was your new year's though did
you do anything fun i was you had a new
year's kiss i was saying i'll tell you
yeah you know what i was stuck
new years to me i thought was so
overrated sometimes i still think it's
overrated but i think
now that i'm in a relationship maybe i
was just bitter
because i wasn't in one all these other
years
right
and being in a relationship on new
year's just it's different
does it like having a new year's kiss
and doing the countdown with someone
it's kind of like a movie
you know
were you guys like like hanging out
together with a big group of people was
it at a bar was it at home no it was
just our friends it was really intimate
but it was so sweet and it was just fun
like everyone around us was fun and i
don't know
no
this is different yeah
it does when you have a relationship too
i feel like i mean for anybody i mean i
don't know if i get sentimental during
new years or something but i know that
when the countdown happens you're just
like okay it's a whole new year not like
oh wait this is the stupid thing it's
like you can kind of feel like that any
day really like if you wanted to start
something new but if there's something
to be said about
it being new years it's like 2022 like
what's gonna happen this time because
you think about you this last year so
different to where you are right now oh
my god can you like think back sophia to
how you were in january last year
actually as opposed to january this year
no remember seriously you can't even
remember and that's actually an
important lesson i think we should pick
up on really quick sometimes when we
think
we're going through something in our
life that seems so
overwhelming and that it's gonna be our
the end of our world and it's just soul
crushing and it takes over every single
cell of your body but then you fast
forward a few weeks a few months and
then even a year and you're like i don't
even remember
what i was feeling what i was so upset
about i mean i remember i was having
mental breakdowns left and right
last january and i couldn't even tell
you what one was about me neither i
can't even tell you
who i was talking to who my friends were
like where i was living i really just
can't remember any of that i can't
remember it okay so i want to hear about
your new years i want to hear about also
okay why don't we start with
why you decided to stay in florida
okay so it wasn't because i just
randomly was like i don't want to go and
i never wanted to go in the first place
like i want to experience all of these
new firsts with sistine like i think
it's been really fun like i hear about
our parents doing these like cool ski
trips or like growing up and things like
that so that's all i really wanted to do
was get to experience that with her but
i don't know if anyone else um also
feels a hammer getting pounded in their
head aka migraines and that's what i was
experiencing towards the end of the end
of the year so
i was just getting uh
hot flashes at night i was getting
severe migraines where poor cysteine was
taking the butt of it um because if you
guys know how migraines feel you feel
like
you are in your own personal health it
is just the worst and so
i made the decision that
if i was going to have all of these
migraines and i couldn't sleep and i was
not feeling great that i wouldn't want
to put that on anybody and especially my
sister's getting to have this really
cool experience with their boyfriend i'm
like you know what it's healthier for me
to stay home and be with parents which i
still love florida so it's nice to be
here with them but then you know i
gotta have to miss out on something that
i definitely had fomo i definitely had
fomo there was times where i featured
like yeah are you kidding like just
because i'm here and i know some people
here and it was easier to acclimate
doesn't mean i wasn't like oh [ __ ] like
yeah of course i've been wanting to go
to sun valley with you guys like right
when you told me about it i was like
let's go i like you you were messing up
you were definitely men it's okay but it
ended up actually being really nice as
you can see i'm tan and blonde i mean
not the lighting in the room is the best
but um it's been good i spent a lot of
time with mom and the dogs and i just
love florida i don't know if she feels
this way too but when we are here for a
long period of time we look
awesome i don't know if it's the
humidity if it's the tan if it's the
ocean i don't know what it is but for my
new years i
went to an event like a small thing with
my parents um
and then i just went to dinner with some
girlfriends and we went out for a hot
second but it wasn't like anything
different but it was really fun because
um
the group was really fun and you know
how we always say that
nothing's fun unless you have a really
good group of people that are all
they're in it they're like we want to
have fun we want to go out we want to
make this a really good time and so yeah
did i get a new year's kiss
no
did i have the opportunity
no no no did i even get to kiss my
friend
no
what did i kiss i literally
your hand
no i like took a shot and i was like
in here
bring it back let's
single again that's okay too i loved it
it was like not a bad new year's
honestly i was kind of i was worried
that i was going to be shitty but i did
go to an event with my parents where i
was bullied there
okay yeah you called me and you were
freaking out about yes what happened let
me explain what happened y'all
i go to the small dinner gatherings my
parents it's their their friends that
are hosting it and i don't know anyone
at this place and i don't know the kids
i don't know the adults i don't know
anybody and so i get placed at a table
with
kids quote kids they're all like 25 to
35.
let's break that down really fast um how
do you feel still getting sat at the
kid's table i don't know i well actually
you know what this time it was fine i
love it
it wasn't a kid's table like 12 year
olds it's kid's table
the kids of the the parents whatever you
know
um where did you go
i'm getting the water oh okay um
because people are probably watching
this going
where did she head out
um yeah so i
is that jello shot from halloween that i
made
what if you guys don't see this
would it be so disgusting if i tried
some of this old yellow shot from
i don't think it'd be horrible you can
try a little bit if you want to try it
oh god so uh if you guys are not
watching this on youtube since you just
found an old jello shot actually syringe
um in the refrigerator so that's cool
that means we have to continue as you
were saying yeah let me explain the
story because this this is also includes
the podcast so
i set this table with 25 year olds and
35 year olds and i don't know any of
them um i'm sitting next to this one guy
i don't really know him either and no
one's really talking and i get there to
the table and i'm like you know what
they all know each other they don't know
me maybe they're sussed out but i'll be
the happy-go-lucky girl so i go up and
they go why i'm sophia i'm shaking
everyone's hand
no one's giving me their name it's like
hi
you know it's like you know what you say
hi i'm sophia you should say like hi i'm
brittany or something like aaron no
there was just hi
okay wait how many people were at the
table a good like 12. it wasn't just you
went out of your way made you around to
all 12 people well i sat i stood at my
chair and i like shook the people that i
could reach around me and the ones that
crossed i like waved i was like hi hi
and so i sat there no one's really
talking to me and this guy looks at me
and he goes what do you do like what are
you doing in l.a like uh where do you
live and i kind of explained it to him i
go oh i actually have a podcast on wax
with my sister
and he goes what do you talk about and i
go oh i talk about
confidence i talk about mental health i
talk about we interview people we talk
about dating and first dates and he goes
whoa whoa whoa you guys have a dating
podcast and i go
well no not necessarily a dating podcast
but i have a
and we do talk about first dates like
red flags all that stuff just for fun
and he literally stops the table as
they're all trying to eat as they're all
talking goes hey everyone
hey everyone by the way i already know
the vibe no one likes me here no hey
everybody
and says
this is sophia
and she has a podcast where she talks
about dating so why don't we all listen
to sophia right now and she tells us
what we should look out for for red
flags which we need to do better
and no one says anything and i look at
the sky and i go hey hey uh you're
putting me on the spot here a little bit
and i don't claim to know anything i
just talk about my horrible first dates
and the guy next to me on the other side
goes yeah let's talk about how shitty
men are and i go oh
my god
do i have like if i was gonna have
haters like a group of haters on like a
um on a um what's the what's that page
that we look up like
read it if i also have a hate group on
reddit they're the leaders of this
they did not like me and the girls are
looking at me in the most guys imagine
gossip girl
everyone's dressed like gossip girl and
imagine the glares
that they can shoot at you it was
and i get up and i go you know what
if you eat sushi that's your favorite
that's red flag good night and i walk
away um i don't say that but i go to mom
and dad i'm like you guys i gotta turn
this night around this is not the crowd
i can't keep doing the like
pony show for them
what why would they just
come at you like that
i you know i i don't know and this is
the thing i called sistine i was really
upset like i was really really upset
because first of all it's embarrassing
that you're [ __ ] on me in front of
people i don't know um i know you guys
think i'm like i can be a bulldog with
some things and cece and i don't mind
calling each other out but i really do
get sensitive about
things where it comes to putting the
tension on me and it's like a negative
light also you're [ __ ] on something
that we've been working hard at for a
year and a half and
making fun of it and just because we
talk about dating they automatically
think i'm like a i don't know like a
leader on something
why do you think
they were being so
maliciously rude for no reason i i don't
know i i don't know if it was i piece
i'll be honest like i didn't walk in
thinking i was like cooler than anything
i i never walk no no
it's not about
how you walk in how they perceive you
why do you think that
they would just do that to a girl that
they don't even know
maybe jealousy or insecurity i don't
know if i i mean i was pretty confident
that night i like worked hard on my
putting my outfit together my hair
makeup i don't know if the girls just
girls being girls and they were trying
to compare and they just didn't like me
on that and i don't really know where
the guy's animosity came from which was
really odd
um
but i i don't know it was i walked into
the room and i'll just be honest like it
did not
feel good like the vibes were not there
if that makes sense so
um yeah it was just weird and i i was
just i i didn't even go back to the
table like i
walked out and i left and i went to a
restaurant and met up with girls and had
a good time okay so you turned the night
around though that's good yeah yeah and
i'm happy to see that you're hanging out
with a bunch of cool people and really
nice girls and
what do you think because i feel like
you're
more social there than you are in los
angeles like what do you think the big
difference is oh yeah
because i want to get your opinion on
this since you you've lived here with me
um and i actually had this conversation
with mom about
people on the west coast versus the east
coast and
uh
the way they go about going out or the
way they socialize and communicate and
whatever it is
and
i've just seen since living on the east
coast more that people are just very
direct and they want to hang out with
you like people want to go to dinners
all the time people want to go take
walks they want to meet up with you for
lunch or coffee and when they say they
want to meet up they do it they follow
through they don't just say like let's
do it
you know and i feel like and you can say
that you can answer this too is
when it's the west coast i feel like
you hear it but no one actually follows
through it's kind of a pain in the ass
to get anywhere
i am
a prime example of that person who
i really do want to hang out with you so
if i say
sophia let's go get a coffee i would
love to catch up with you i really do
mean that
but then the idea the execution of
actually getting ready going out to get
coffee
finding parking coming up with
conversation it's not that hard when
you're actually there doing it but the
whole process to get there gives me such
weird social anxiety and then i'd rather
just say oh screw it i'm not gonna do it
at all and i don't feel like getting
coffee anymore but then i get sad
because i think i missed out on an
opportunity where i totally agree i
think that east coast people
i actually this is my theory i think a
lot of east coast kids
uh
grew up going to boarding school because
that was very popular in the east coast
and still is
and so when you're away from your home
and you spend so many years you know
relying on
friends and classmates that you're
living with full-time as like your new
sort of family and home
you have to
force yourself to be social and follow
through with plans or else like you're
going to be left in the desk whereas in
la i think a lot of people are more
comfortable and coddled and
okay with the idea of being alone or
just with your family or yeah maybe i
don't know i i by the way that's exactly
what i said to mom and i was thinking i
just think that they're just more social
people they're just more people that are
okay with yeah leaving the house or not
because in la
our house is our sanctuary so and also
i would say the nightlife in la isn't
necessarily one you want to go out all
the time too like the restaurants even
too it's kind of a hassle to get
somewhere when even if it's florida or
new york or whatever it's a taxi right
away it's a walk away it's a yeah it's
two seconds away and so it's been nice
being here because um
i'm constantly getting us like hey let's
go get lunch let's go get coffee let's
go get dinner and i'm thinking okay yeah
sure i'll say yes and then they're like
no no like what time
wait
okay don't get too comfortable don't get
too comfortable no no no no no i miss
you
is coming right back home
no i miss you i miss you i actually
really really do miss you we have lots
to do you know we do
we got a lot of things coming up
i think there's some news i actually
haven't even told you that's coming up
that's possible you know what i'm you
know what i'm so excited for
what we actually have a lot of things
coming up in l.a that we should talk
about
but i'm so excited
i have so much gossip
and just key
to tell you i don't go
i
don't want to do it on facetime i so
badly want to get dinner with you drink
a cocktail oh wait you know where we do
this don't kill me don't kill me no no
don't kill me
i decided to do sober january
no drinking
all of january
what do you think
have you started
yeah
but okay so i'll tell you
do you know why i'm pissed
because we're going to be cutting this
yeah so for sistine's birthday or
christmas present
i got her tickets
on the ice and at this really cool
restaurant downtown to go to a king's
game on the ice when i say how nice i
mean on the ice right next to the the
ranger
anymore coldness
oh god
no okay i'll i'll explain maybe yeah
for another day
oh my god
i'll do a path for for the kings game
but i
don't ever drink excessively but i do
think that um
it's the holiday season it's just
natural that you
accidentally drink more and you go to
more holiday parties and there's
thanksgiving and then there's christmas
and there's new year's and it's just a
lot and um
i always feel really good when i don't
drink and i remember i used to do this i
do it at least once a year i just pick a
different month and so i said you know
what
i'm gonna do january
just to see how far i can get and if i
break it i'm not going to beat myself up
because i probably will
um but i just want to try it
i don't disagree with you because i have
been drinking
a lot a lot here like on random days
that last i had two glasses of wine with
mom why you're doing it no because but
that's adulting i think as you get older
you just have a drink with every meal
because you can
because you can but yeah i just and it's
it's not a resolution that i made for
new year's which by the way i hate
keeping
new year's resolutions because
one making a goal
that long term to carry for an entire
year
is impossible i can barely remember what
i had for breakfast yesterday how much
this remember resolution i made actually
sophia i'll ask you this right now do
you remember i'm pretty sure we shared
our resolutions like two episodes ago
you should remember what yours was
to walk in the room with confidence
oh
yeah it was like to walk into yeah to
never like go into a room not feeling
the night that we went to that one club
that remember how i was like super
confident
yeah i've held that actually i'll be
honest
i can't even remember
i see that's the thing you have to make
it super simple and i also think you can
start new year's resolutions whenever
you want
start it that's true if you guys were
like i forgot what it was what are you
feeling right now after the new the
countdown just hit what was the first
thing you thought of that you wanted to
do that's your new year's resolution
okay
right
yeah
fair
anyway you coming back to l.a
right yes and i'm so excited
we have to have so i have someone to
talk about with you since i've been here
stuff has gone on
oh my that's what's so crazy i love when
we do spend some time apart because then
it's just the ultimate every reunion
when we come back together i know
but something else that's very exciting
that sofia and i
are doing
very soon in the future is we are
moving out
of
the broken
town house wait guys everyone is
probably thinking didn't you just move
in
the answer yes yes
we did joshua
actually yes we did just move in but as
we were saying and complaining 800 times
to y'all
it's just it's just really a bad place
it's just by the way also it's not safe
everything breaks down
i'll tell you what my final straw was
as if the roaches weren't enough as if
the ceiling leaks weren't enough is it
carbon dioxide monoxide wasn't enough i
will tell you the straw that broke the
camel's back
[Music]
i was trying to heat up french toast in
the microwave
and guess what happened to the microwave
it exploded
it exploded
it exploded
microwaves
well now how you heard it here folks
no but like
i'm done i'm good you know it's a pain
and especially since it hasn't even been
a full year
and
nothing
nothing is working and you guys we're
not even complaining like we haven't
even included all of the leaks
leaks within us like in every single
room that pops up once a month the black
water that comes out of our faucets you
guys think we're living
the most happy outlets don't work i
think people think that we live in like
some super nice place that we're just
like spending whatever no no no
we definitely chose we chose this place
and it's just not working anymore so
we're building
we're building character with this place
yeah we're moving out but sophie and i
decided that
we should get two
one bedrooms
next to each other
i don't think she was so on board with
that in the beginning okay
well i'll this is i i just like living
with you and i think it's fun uh waking
up the morning and we just have our
little coffee talk but
but since uh since you've kind of been
talking about it more i think it
actually does make sense because you and
i
we don't want to live apart but we think
that it would be better since we as we
say eat sleep live live like we are
super co-dependent on each other and she
has a boyfriend now to have some space
and decorate her own place and start to
kind of you know like you you need that
time like i i like to wake up super
early in the morning you know
you know what you're gonna miss out on
your coffee yes and i will be waking up
every morning early to turn it on for
you
you're gonna walk over to my place make
it and then leave wait that's the thing
is you guys you think we're moving like
away we're living on the same floor next
to each other
two feet apart
i'm actually so excited for that i think
it's to be cool you said you've made a
vision board right i've already started
decorating it i'm so excited i i already
know exactly what i want i've picked out
all of my furniture already
i'm so excited i'm just
i don't know
no it's exciting it's like another
chapter it's something to look forward
to for this new year but you've you've
actually never lived alone that right
you've never lived alone um
not alone alone like i've lived in
another room but no i've lived like no
you've had roommates i've had roommates
but most of the time like my roommates
would never be there
so it was like i was living alone but i
haven't actually had an apartment
yeah no no i've never done that you did
that in new york for a year
i think you'll like it
i'm excited i actually think i'll like
it because also you're near me so it's
not gonna be that bad yeah but it'll be
cool to see what our styles are
uh when we start today what's something
that you're gonna
definitely not miss
living with me
hmm
um
i won't miss
you complaining that i spoke coffee
grinds everywhere and you're like did
you take out the trash did you do this
did you do this like you think i don't
do anything like you just don't you
don't do it i do i do you don't take out
the trash every single time you think it
just randomly
failed and like empty whatever
what about me
i i knew mine right away
oh
i won't miss okay sophia i don't know
why you do this but
say if i'm
grabbing
a rice cake or a date or a snack or
whatever you always
rip it in half and then leave the other
half in the bag
a lot i'm like
like what am i supposed to do with with
this have you ignored it
yeah
take that one out to get the one
underneath and put that one back okay
that's not that hard you just take it
out and you put it back in this cake
something you haven't watched
or the whole date
okay well you know what no it's fine i'm
excited to move out and live near you
not with you
um okay actually
um i wanted to bring this up because i
read about this in the new york post and
i wrote this down actually wait you said
you sat next to someone on the plane do
you want to get into that
oh my god i forgot about this
um
yeah you guys know that i just am such a
fan of weirdos on planes and i always
sit next to the good ones and of course
i sat next to another cook on a plane a
little kooky guy
uh
so i i
was on my way to sun valley and luckily
it was a very short flight
and i sit next to this guy
the fact you got home you were able to
get a flight home is i know
every flight was canceled that was
mostly aspen um
this guy had i kid you not the world's
smallest dog i've never seen a dog so
small in my entire life
i've eaten a burrito bigger than this
dog it was so tiny and it was really
really cute and they're like oh do you
want to hold it and i was like no i'm
afraid i always get nervous when i hold
people's
small dogs and babies because my first
reaction is i'm gonna drop it so i don't
i don't want to be responsible so i'm
like oh no no it's okay i'll just pet it
and then he starts like
smelling the dog's paws but really going
like taking a whiff like
me
it was like smelling it like
i was doing that
and i
just like
okay
interesting and he goes oh my god it
smells so good puppy pasta smell the
dogs paws smell them you're joking yeah
it gets better i get what because no
smell smell how good
that my dog's paws are like they smell
so good i was like no it's fine no no
smell them no
i smelled them
what's wrong with you
just as creepy as a man
that's not any better than that
how do you say no
you say no thank you
wait i'll show you right now oh for
people i think i'm lying
yeah i don't i believe you but i don't
understand why
look at the flaws
yeah sistine was it everything you
wanted him more i'm not gonna lie the
pocket don't horrible
you're so gross probably he was stopping
his own [ __ ] or something no it was not
good i was like
i wanted to tell this because um
the reason why i brought this up and i
read it i was like i feel like i do this
a lot when it comes to you know we
always like to talk about dating but i
read about this article about what
millennials are doing
this upcoming year and it's called it's
a new dating trend
and it is called
hardballing
so it was made popular by gen z
and it's so that means it's probably
like 24 25 and younger and it involves a
lot of
maybe hurt me hurting and like truth
telling and early dumpings so basically
what you do is
you
tell them basically instantly what
you're looking for in the relationship
whether it's
hi
this is me i wanna fling or hi i'm
looking for marriage probably the next
five years and if you're aligned
great if you're not aligned
ow cut out so it's just if your match
doesn't play like if it isn't aligned
with theirs then it's an instant goodbye
it's called hard balling so basically
gen z's are like being very upfront
about what they want in a relationship
they're not wasting
oh okay so it's not a
dating show or an app or anything this
is literally no it's a type of dating
yes no it's a new dating trend it's just
called hardballing
so it's if i went up to a guy and i said
i want kids in the next five years i'm
gonna get married that's my goal i'm not
looking for something
easy i'm looking for something long-term
yeah and if they say
oh yeah i want to be long-term but i'm
not looking for kids
out instantly you don't even give it a
chance to say oh maybe it might work out
even if it probably you guys are
compatible
personality wise or humor or whatever
so what do you think about that
well okay see it's it's interesting
because you know how people say that
like women sort of have a timeline they
have to go by
and you know the longer that you wait to
for example
get pregnant um
you know the higher risk you are
uh
and so i think that that's good if
you're a certain
age and window that you're actually
looking for
you know a husband or a family or
whatever it is so maybe you like for me
right now hardballing seems way too
harsh and it's going to crush my little
ego and would make me really sad
because i don't want to know someone's
opinion of me
that severely but if i was
so i think you're misreading what it is
no no but listen
no like
no
no for example say if you're like i want
kids and they're like no i have kids i
don't want that you'll be like
well what the hell like
you know no i would say okay then we're
not a match but see what i'm saying is
if i was maybe 29
i would love to you know
do this hardball dating because then i
know for fact what i'm getting because
sometimes dating is fun right now you
get to figure out and you get to
find compromises and differences are
good too
i
agree but i
completely disagree at the same time and
this is how does that make sense it
makes sense because basically for me i
would say i'm considered you're
considered gen z and this is like
younger kids doing it they're not older
if i want something that's simple and i
want to fling
i'm gonna make it known that this is a
flank i'm not gonna waste time and let
this person think that they're because
what if you're what if you were going
out with a guy and you said to him that
i want a fling and he thought the whole
time that you wanted a relationship
that's shitty for you not to be upfront
and tell them the truth that you were
not looking for anything serious or vice
versa for him imagine if he
was going on eight dates with you and
you had no idea that he was seeing four
other people because he just wanted to
fling but you didn't look i'm not saying
that the approach is correct i don't
think you need to be first date like
these are my requirements this is what
i'm looking for and if you don't have
them i'm out i think that's a little bit
immature and a little bit
jumping the gun but
what i would say is even at my like i'm
only 25
like i know what i'm looking for i'm
looking for something that's not a fling
i'm looking for something that is a bit
more substantial so
eventually i would hope for on the third
date maybe to bring that up and say okay
i i hope you're on the same page with me
here because i don't want to waste my
time
but you see the problem is most guys
that we go out with today you ask them
hard-hitting questions like that and
they immediately go into their hermit
crab shell then they are
then they are immature and you shouldn't
go out with them okay sophia then you
are the guinea pig you start hardball
dating
2022.
why not hardball date
you don't ask these questions i don't
but it's not the points not to like ask
the questions like a psycho and go if
you're not there today it's more like
you casually bring it up if the guy is
saying
oh yeah i'm not interested in marriage
at all i don't want to get married i
just want to travel the world and not
have kids which is totally fine totally
fine
but
it's good to know and then that means
yeah i don't want to do that or if
that's like what you want to do that's
great i think i do agree with you in
some ways but i feel like if you take a
bit of hard balling in a way and kind of
go okay i'm not going to lower my
standards or change what i'm looking for
for a guy
you know what i'm saying i think it's
it's important because like imagine i
mean you and your boyfriend like you
guys both went in with the same
intention the exact same one
how how would you feel if you like went
on a couple dates with them and then
within like two months he was like you
know i was this wasn't supposed to be
serious it was supposed to be a fling oh
i've been there
like exactly
and it sucks
it sucks so i think that
2022 if y'all are hard balling
don't do it in an aggressive way be a
little bit nicer about it but i also
think don't lower your standards and be
upfront about what you want because you
know time is precious and you don't want
to waste it dating someone that wasn't
your match in the first place and yeah
the differences are good but when it
comes to the
ground bases of like moral stuff and
like whatever it is that are deal
breakers for you then
like
you know
thanks i just thought that was
interesting because i was reading a lot
of 20 year olds were doing that i was
like that's a little young they'd
probably be doing that
but i guess one year old
20 year olds
not one year olds
21 year old yeah it says millennials are
doing this
i mean
i made a joke you didn't get my joke no
i can't well you were glitchy for a
second
yeah
so speaking of dating um i was watching
the news with mom yesterday and i wanted
to bring this up because it was really
sad but it was really um kind of like a
good thing to think about and it kind of
puts life into perspective so basically
in times square this mom
puts her daughter's dating profile
in the middle of everything and uh it's
using this do you know which one i'm
talking about
no but i would die
imagine it's like meet my daughter for
her name chloe she is 25. she loves this
it's in the middle of times square this
mom puts it up it's using the stadium
called um wingman the wingman um ceo put
it up for the mom so it's all over it's
blasted everywhere
and so um
i was watching this i was like mom if
you ever did that i would kill you i
would kill you and we continued watching
and it was really sad because
um the mom goes on to explain saying um
i had cancer and it came back and it's
in my bones now and so
my daughter is trying to find someone to
marry so that i can walk her down the
aisle and so the ceo of um wingman
put it up for the mom
i know so the mom is like going to pass
away soon and so the mom was saying on
the thing like all i want to do is see
my daughter go down the aisle and i want
to do it before i pass away
and so
it was i was like literally tearing up
mom was tearing up and it was so
um
sweet and sad and you can just see their
bond and they reminded me of us and our
mom and
i don't know it just kind of shows you
like it puts things in perspective for a
hot second it's hard to be like live
every day to your last or whatever but
oh god heartstrings
you know it really shows too that
everyone wants to find love and everyone
really wants to be loved
as much as people don't want to admit it
and that just shows the daughter wants
to find someone and the mom wants her
daughter to be in love and like that's
yeah
well you know what she said that's what
it's all about
no the [ __ ] that's funny you said that
because the two things she said was
she's like i want to see my daughter
walk down the aisle and i want to know
that my daughter's happy with someone
good before i pass away oh
sistine
she's like all i want to do is go and
know my daughter is with someone that's
good and is making her happy
i
lost it
mom of course lost it you know
hearing stuff like that
although it really puts a horrible ball
in my throat
it really is important to
listen to stories like these because
although it is really hard to hear
stories like that
and
as much as it makes you
want to cry and
um
share it with your friends and
their pass it on
it really is important to look inward
and
look at your own life and see how lucky
you are
and that you know you're healthy and you
have
family that loves you your friends that
love you
and
that girl is very lucky she has a
daughter i mean a mom that really loves
her i mean
oh god that is just
how did you share that why would you
share that with me
well i just feel like sorry i know
sustained
i know i know i just i just heard it and
i thought like
i mean all i like oh yeah you were right
everyone wants is to i mean not everyone
but i feel like a lot of people want to
find love and be in love and all that
stuff and it i look at mom when i was
when we were talking and i was thinking
yeah it's really hard every single day
to wake up with this idea that if
tomorrow was my last day like what would
i be doing it's i mean because life is
hard we're gonna have our ups and downs
you're gonna wake up sad or wake up
happier and wake up
hungover not hungover or whatever it is
but it's really important to kind of
take a step back and go okay
if i was hurt and i only had a few
months
what are the things that are so
important right now if you guys are
going to go into 2022 with any
perspective or mindset go into it kind
of like that saying okay
i want to find good people around me i
want to have a really great job and be
happy with my life and have positivity
and great friends and memories or
whatever it is that makes you happy but
i hope this mom and daughter find the
guy that she's been looking for and that
they have this wedding and i could see
it all live because
amen all right amen amen
yeah let's do it
so this person said
this is a funny question
what is something that absolutely
frightened you as a kid
something that absolutely frightened you
as a kid that's easy
oh can i guess yours and you can guess
mine
yeah
coraline
that was one of them yeah
okay
um something to frighten you clown
obviously yeah well it i'll tell you
clown killer yeah the clown color that
story of uh
john
quincy i don't know what his name was
but yeah clowns are not my thing
anything that involved clowns when i
went to circus soleil as a kid that
stuff was not my thing a clown came up
to me and touched my face and that was
the moment i decided
i have it out for clowns i will run i
will hide i will jump in the water
and i will
lose my [ __ ] so yeah i wanted to be a
clown for halloween just to freak you
out i would i wouldn't talk to you
i wouldn't talk to you
i feel well i know your fear is full
like deep water sausaphobia you can't
see what's underneath
colossal phobia
i feel like your fear as a kid
you like scary movies though so there's
not a lot of things that really scare
you like you loved the nightmare before
christmas that really creepy guy that's
full of bugs
you know
jack skellington
you love him what scared me as a kid
the movie monster house
freaked me out i can't tell you and
pan's labyrinth
freaked me out oh fair jumanji
but the original jumanji
really scared me that's so funny it
scared me too
yeah oh my god it was horrifying and um
uh american horror story
uh
season one sistine do you want to hear
that those are i think you and i were
together during this and this is a funny
story we're at our cousin's house and it
was the first episode of the first
season of american horror story and we
are in their like little movie room and
we're laying down as kids it's probably
late at night we're having our little
milkshakes
and the scene that pops up that i will
never forget that you and i didn't sleep
for like days after watching this was
when the nurse was tied up and her face
was down on the couch and the guy was
just stabbing her over and over in the
back
yeah you know i watched it recently and
i was like oh it's not that scary it
probably wasn't that scary but when we
watched it originally we were freaked
out i think we're younger but i'll tell
you this if you guys
watch pan's labyrinth
today
dm me and let me know if it scares you
because it's still god that gives me
such nightmares i mean the guy with the
eyeballs on the hand
i don't like anything about where they
can't see you and they hear you
well i am coming home soon and i cannot
wait to see you it's gonna be so much
fun catching up
um but you guys we actually have an id
mom and dad are coming back to ellie
soon which is really exciting
maybe we do a
mom dad episode where we do a couples
questions for them
i think that sounds like a brilliant
idea sofia
perfect well thank you guys so much for
listening to unwaxed podcasts and yes
this is the last time you'll see us
doing a zoom like this it's always going
to be together next time so you do not
very nostalgic by the way
i know this is really nostalgic super
weird super super yes thank you guys so
much for listening to this week's
episode we promise we will see you next
tuesday make sure you subscribe to our
youtube apple podcast spotify
listen on all those platforms follow us
on
on whack podcast on instagram take
comments comment comment comment leave
us reviews that helps us a lot
yes and if you want your unsolicited
advice answered make sure you go to the
apple podcast page
leave your question in the ratings and
review section give us five stars
we love you so much thank you so much
you guys for listening we will see you
next tuesday bye
[Music]
you